اعداد المصابين بفايروس كورونا لا تزال في
ازدياد بعد ان انهت الحكومه الصينيه فجاه
شهر الماضي سياسه صفر
وبينما تقول سلطاته الصحيه الصينيه ان
اعداد المصابين بالفيروس والوفيات الناتجه
عنه لا يتجاوزوا عده الاف منظمه الصحه
العالميه والباحثون يقدرون هذه الاعداد
بالملايين انتشار الوباء من جديد في الصين
دفع بعدد من الدول كفرنسا وايطاليا
واسبانيا وامريكا ومؤخرا اليابان الى فرد
اجراءات فحص عشوائيا للركاب الوافدين من
الصين او مطالباتهم بتقديم نتائج فحص صلبه
اجراءات تنتقدوها بكين بشده وتراها غير
منطقي
الوقايه من الوباء التي تتخذها الدول يجب
ان تكون على اساس علميه ولا يجب استخدامها
في تلاعب سياسي او ممارسه تميزيه على
التعاون بين الناس
ومؤخرا قام الاتحاد الاوروبي بتقديم مقترح
الى الصين يقتدي بارسال اللقاحات الغربيه
الفائضه الى بكين كمحاوله لاحتواء انتشار
من قبل الصين
معدلات الطاقه
العلاجيه ووسعت انتاج الموارد الطبيه
وقامت بتوفير الامدادات الطبيه الكافيه
اجتماعا لتنسيق القرارات المتعلقه بوصول
الوافدين من الصين الى دول الاتحاد في ظل
مخاوف من ظهور متحور جديد من فيروس كورونا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه